so this is forward to the project when i
came here i was like oh my god i'm just
going to fill this with bits
so i'm super happy to be in this stage
um so as
andreas i am super penalized i am
working at mozilla by the day
so i'm an apps engineer make apps help
people make apps
but by night i'm super solid so that's
when i get to make noises
and like blew up my neighbors so what
we're going to see today is
first i'll just give you a little bit of
background so you know where i came from
then i'll show you what i built and then
i'm going to blow up your minds or your
ears
you never know so you know when you go
in a plane and you hear brace brace and
they say you hear brace brace just cover
your ears
so if you hear that run because it's
like
it's blowing up and it's going to damage
your ears
so as you might have understood i love
music
and one of the first gifts i got when i
was a child was a blue vinyl lp
and i thought it was like something like
this tall and
i just couldn't stop listening to that
it was like one of those horrible child
bands it was like
but i just couldn't stop it so i was
like can i listen to that again and they
were like
it was a turntable you couldn't just put
it in a loop like an itunes you had to
go put the needle back so it was like
this tall and the turntable was here so
it was like trying to reach out it was
like my early challenge
and then the 80s were good times so we
had
cheese electric poop with video games
and casio keyboards amazing so this was
mine
it was like six notes polyphony six or
eight instruments and zero frames it was
like kind of limited
and for recording you had to record to a
tape which wasn't ideal
but it was fine and the 90s came
what that meant was multimedia which was
like oh my god see the wrong players and
stuff
and trackers i don't even hear about
trackers it's like a sample based music
program
so i could do lots of music and i got
into the demo scene as well which is
like
graphics bit cubes everything all at the
same time
and then vijaying which is like the same
but real time
and i got to go to go to live gigs and i
got someone to
play some visuals while i was playing
music which was pretty exciting but
it's hard to coordinate with people
especially if your friends live in
another country like
like it was this case um so i got like
introverted and got
two software synthesis and i started
building my own synthesizers with
c and c plus plus and i made virtual
instruments which is
like a technology so you can have
synthesizers with cubase or any other
kind of software the problem with that
is that it's hard to distribute because
can
part of the sdk is properly dry so you
can't really distribute that
and instructions for building that are
really confusing because you have to say
well this this part you can use it but
then you have to go to cubase
download something that i can distribute
because it's closer
so it was hard to get it to work for
more people than me
even though some people distributed that
in line of distribution which is pretty
amazing like it's so hard
still people made the effort so that was
exciting and then
he's like ah yeah this is my turn
um and he got where audio is like yes
webgl absolutely and node.js and
i could be a one woman orchestra it's
like i don't need anyone else
i can do everything myself so i wanted
the video output and all the hardware
input
and i could glue everything with node.js
so
i got this thing it's a q new hardware
controller
which is for hackers it's got pressure
sensitive pads with leds
you can't really see that because it's
really bright but there are
leds here and it's small
oops the nice thing is that it uses
gdp i think you've heard about udp but
it's like
obviously you've heard about udp i mean
oh you see oh opens up control it's like
a protocol you can use for connecting
between
um different instruments and controllers
and everything it's like midi but motor
like the the big brother of
of media um so
this thing comes with something called
oec bridge which converts your usb data
into something that or any other
internet aware program like
knows candice um so with
a nice module that someone already has
made i could just
read whatever this thing sends me and i
can also send things to that so for
example if i
if i press here it's just listening the
touch events and sending so i'm just
getting messages here
and then i can also send messages here
so i can control the colors
that you can really see again because
it's very bright
and then that's for the input but what
do we do in
in the browser because we want to make
it sound so
it's okay yeah that's evident
um and then the way this works is
um with openstack control you kind of
subscribe to addresses it's like
um
silence um it's like uh like
urls so you can match things with reach
regular expressions like these things so
for example when i press a pad
i get sent a message with that structure
and i can
say i'm interested only in pressing pad
so i'm just subscribing to that i'm
filtering everything else and with
socket io i'm sending everything
from udp to this thing to the browser
and
just listen to whatever i'm interested
in and then i can also send messages
again you can see that but each path has
like four leds and i can control the red
and the green values
so again i can turn the whole thing red
whole thing green or
somewhere in between and then
that's for the path obviously i had to
do something that might sound
so previously i used to build my whole
thing
like totally ignoring audio i was just
using
the um script notes i was like
everything like it was like if it was
still c plus plus but then i thought i
could do this
with proper web audio using all the apis
from the audio and
make it very modular like i can include
one thing which and the other
and reuse as much as possible
so the problem with that is that the
very very native
web audio stuff is very very native and
it's very very limited
so you have to write lots of wrappers
and for example the
oscillators when whenever a voice just
stops playing it just disappears into
the user
so you need to make something so that
you can detect okay this node has
finished you need to
regenerate that so you need to go making
lots of little things like that they are
not very
difficult but they are not as intuitive
and they seem to be
finding people by surprise a lot and
another thing that i think is
interesting is i made a little envelope
i don't know if you know about envelopes
it's basically if you got an instrument
and you pay
always in the same volume it's boring
it's like
you need to give a little bit of
expression so way of doing that is
having
volume changes so you can do that with
envelopes envelope is basically attack
decay sustain release so i build that
which kind of
automates the way you can change
parameters with audio which is something
like set value time
set parameter at time that's you don't
want to do that all the time so you just
automate that with a class
so that was for the basic things but
sometimes there were
times that i didn't have enough things
like for example i wanted to multiply
the output of two nodes but i don't
think there's anything really that does
it so you can just shame it with a
custom node which is pretty
good and obviously
you want to change things so i may agree
and this is this is using um
this is attached to whatever i created
so
it's based on web components i don't
know about that thing so
if it's available it's fine if it's not
extract will shame everything away and
just don't worry about that so the way
it works i create instances of that and
then
i attach them to real virtual
instruments i created
um because as event phased whatever i
do in the in degree
just reflects on the instrument so i
could be changing the release time and
it should be changing
so it's longer release or shorter
so and if it changes that
programmatically it would change as well
but
i'm not going to live program here
um so the first thing i
brought was the bajotron which is a
funny game
who worked with spanish and english so
it's like bass drone
and it's a more funny multivoicing
unisonic bachelling
so it makes that it only plays one note
multivoices because it's got more than
one oscillator and unisonic is because
they
are playing in different octaves and
it's a bass line
so this is that and then it made the
culture nature
which is like um it's like a pot
potato because culture in spanish is a
path
um i just like to make funny names for
things
so i built i i started like reusing
things so i just took
instances of the previous instrument i
put them inside these things so i've got
like multi
polyphonic instrument just with the
previous one for this i had to create
what they call a voice allocation unit
so you can decide okay i've got
three voices and you're sending me four
notes so the
first one is out so you need to
implement some sort of criteria for
building this thing and then it is porn
pom
which is like a drum machine because
porn poem in spanish is the way
you kind of represent the sound of a
drum from poem
so it's just plain samples it's like um
an 808 or 909 or something
like this um
and then remember i don't even know how
to pronounce this
reverb phone is a impulse based repair
model
which i included that's inside the
cultivator
because what is this thing you can see
here um
actually the way for the reptron is
inside the way for the other thing
everything is inside it's like the
matrix or inception or something
um so you can i'm using web audio
reverbs things so it's using
samples for representing how the reverb
should be behaving
i'm not sure it's seen very well but
basically
they go to our room an empty room and
put some mics somewhere and
they record and that's what i'm because
that's what i'm using that's how they
record the way the sound reacts to
different environments
so the nice thing is that whenever the
new buffer is loaded i just
load it and draw it with canvas so it's
pretty amazing i'm just throwing an ogg
file here it's like
yeah i love this thing um
so yeah just back to the other thing um
and obviously you need something because
otherwise i can't be a
one-woman orchestra so i made something
to go with the music and that's of
course webgl by
38js and the thing is that
i think this is something that many
people find confusing how do you render
many times
of using only one renderer it's very
easy actually
and i'll explain later and i'm not going
to
complicate with the scenes because i'm
not a 3d artist i just made some cubes
and stuff
they look kind of simple and minimal so
that should be fine
so yeah the trick it's a very simple
trick
you create the render like this you say
please don't
delete whatever when you're done and
then don't auto clear
and then you when you render you say
render clear ones and then
repeat render for each thing you want to
render that should be due
you don't need anything else that's it
and for playing live obviously you can't
be doing everything at the same time so
i
i don't know if you heard about renoise
has anyone used
green noise or any tracker ever
no i can't believe that okay
so basically everybody knows it's like a
modern tracker and
it's like any other sequencer you
basically prepare
a song with this thing um it's a tracker
in the future i would like to have my
own web editor but that would be like
maybe 10 years time when i have time you
know for that so in the meantime i just
made the song with another software like
i'm not reinventing this wheel this time
um so the good thing about this editor
is that the song format is xml
so but i don't want to use xml so i
export it to json
and there wasn't any module for that so
i made another anode module for this
um and the thing about tracker consists
i really like
way more than reason or qas or anything
is that
it's got these concepts of patterns
tracks and row and some people say that
it's like excel because it's like
one page of data and it's numbers that's
how you sequence that it's very hacker
like
so because it's like pages of things and
you just say place this
page in this order and pay this page
again and paste
so it's like very easy to know what's
playing
and when and which row it is and
everything so you can make very
interesting things with that
and so once you've got the order list
which is like this page and this page
and this page on this page
you just what i'm doing is i'm just
creating a list of events
so i can know what to do when i play
live and
this is the kind of events i get like
not on the node number
timestamp and then the order pattern rom
that's the thing that
you can get from the trackers and then
instrument volume that's obvious so this
obviously you don't know what's playing
um
and why do you want to keep the order
the pattern and the row because
imagine you're playing any
sort of song and you want to keep with
track of which bar
you're in so you can make interesting
things with that so that's why
and you need to sort by times down
ascending timestamp because you need to
schedule the all the events at precise
times obviously you're not going to be
reordering the array of the time because
it's going to like melt your brows
so you want to make it like prepare as
much as possible before you start doing
the heavy thing
so you schedule everything at precise
times but
the problem with werewolves events that
you can't cancel them
so you can just prepare everything and
send everything to the browser because
if you stop it or pause it it's going to
keep playing and you don't want to do
that
so what you need to do is request
audition frame
this is something i made up maybe it's
not the best thing but it kind of works
so what it does
is periodically it goes and looks at the
list of events and says okay
so this buffer is this length what can i
fit in here
okay so i'm just going to dispatch this
like play this note and stop this thing
and
launch this envelope and that kind of
thing
but the problem is that sometimes it can
be off
but you need to be aware of what's going
on most of the people don't really
notice
but again people don't even notice when
pictures aren't pixelated and things
like that this might be just purists
like me
but is there and
how do you make the most of no data so
the tracker gives me this c4 thing and
you can convert them to midi note
numbers
and then because these numbers you can
use maths
which is really always amazing with
music so for example with maths you can
say
this note for for getting the higher
tape you just add
12 to the number so you can do this kind
of funny things like
building chords or arpeggios which is
like
and it's all done with numbers so you
just use the note okay you complain
things but
it's not the same thing um yeah why
bother
with this then the insert js like i
could just hook
this thing to the output and that should
be enough
um but the problem is that for example
if i've got a base
drum like which is like and then i've
got a bass
and they're both playing the same
frequency it's hard for dancer to say
this is this is the drum or this is the
bass so they can't really tell so that
way
you still have you can still have the
fft if you want
but you can also know what's actually
playing and which note is it actually
playing in
um so that's why i explained
um yeah if you use the answer
you need to deal with three holes attack
and the catans
and you know it's very different and it
can change from song to song so it's not
true for all the songs
it's a good chance careful be very
careful this is why i warn you like
sometimes these clips
i hope it doesn't but the the first
things i made they were i was like
adding many voices at the same time
it was like i just had to take my
headphones off it was like
killing my ears so you need to be very
very aware of
possibilities of clipping so the
solution for this is you have um
limiters and compressors as much as you
can or as you need
so that nothing can go over one or minus
one
and the other problem is that it can
break
because it's changing the i mean we will
do things
changing a lot especially for example
with nightly every day there are new
things
happening changing improving up until
two days ago
this was leaking like heavily and you
could close chrome
you was still playing and was like why
is it playing there's nothing here yes
close the window but the window was
still there somewhere
i don't know where but it was there it
didn't even show an activity monitor
i don't know weird um but i guess it's
part of the fun
we are here for having fun and breaking
things and enjoying that
so right
okay good so let's see if it breaks
yeah remember about this thing
thank you
right
it's working
it's breaking
feet
so
i can't stop it
stop it okay
i'm sorry
i think we're done right
yeah awesome
uh can we get a round of applause
awesome to have a presentation that is
worthy of this set
uh i feel like i'm at eurovision um do
we have any questions
uh you have to raise your hands we have
uh we have angeline on mike back there
so even if you're back there it's
totally cool
uh yes hi
um so you were playing like something
with one hand and then
changing the settings with the other
hand right um
would it be possible to connect some
kind of controller so that you don't
have to use your mouse
yeah yeah i just need time okay so in
theory you've got this thing where
you can have i mean this is like the
whole point of the sliders but
i i wanted to map it like instead of
pressing the mouse i could map this
thing
but time i thought that was very cool
yeah thank you